oh boy TV lovers I'm Lana Galera and  this is ship worthy the only show  devoted to celebrating the most swoon  worthy couples on TV your heart beats  faster they want pie so here's a little  bit about me I'm a wildly passionate TV  fan and when I'm watching my favorite  shows each week I tend to become  emotionally invested in my favor on  screen romances sorry not sorry so I  wanted to create ship worthy a show  where fellowship errs like you can come  in gush with me about our favorite TV  couples reliving their best and naughty  or nice scenes and checking out  exclusive interviews from the stars  themselves if you strongly ship any  other TV couples I want to know about it  comment or tweet me with your  nominations of who you think I should  feature on future episodes of ship  worthy and why you love them there was  something about you  join me on the high seas and happy  shipping  you  [Music]